Speaker 1: Donald Trump is demanding
a redo of the 2022 election in Arizona
in what we are calling an electron rant and
electron rant. This is really up there as an
iconic presidential moment of all time. And you'll
see what I mean in a moment. Donald Trump posting
to his platform truth, social truth.
Speaker 4: Essential.
Speaker 1: Quote. So in Maricopa County,
they are at it again. Voting machines in
large numbers didn't work, but only
in Republican districts. Remember,
this isn't true. There were like a couple of
tabulators that had an issue. Everything was fine.
People were forced to wait for hours, then got
exhausted or had other things to do and left the
voting lines by the thousands. Even Carrie Lake
was taken to a liberal Democrat district in order
to vote. Others weren't so lucky. Now, remember,
nobody was told to leave and go to other polling
places. It was a Republican who was actually doing
that. Okay. This is a scam and voter fraud. No
different than stuffing the ballot boxes. They
stole the capital e electron from Blake Masters.
Do election over again. Ladies and gentlemen,
we have nothing to fear but fear itself.
Ask not what your country can do for you,
but what you can do for your country.
We do things not because they are easy, but
because they are hard. They stole the electron.
Do election over again. Really an iconic moment,
inspiring and just electric in presidential
statements of history. Forget the typo for
a second. As funny as it is, it is shocking
that a former president still doesn't know how the
vote counting process works it. How many times do
we have to do this until Trump will understand
or any of them, quite frankly, why it is that
votes are counted the way they are counted? And
I think it's important to remind people, again,
in many of these states, the votes are counted
the way they are counted because of Republican
legislatures that have put in place the rules for
how the vote count works. Add to that, by the way,
that at this point the most scrutinized state
in terms of voting security is probably Arizona,
maybe Pennsylvania to some degree because of what
happened in 2020. But there is no state that is
more scrutinized than Arizona. Within Arizona, I
don't think there's any county more scrutinized
than Maricopa County at this point in time because
of what happened in 2020, thanks to Trump. In
other words, because of all the claims Trump made
in 2020 about Arizona. Arizona and Maricopa County
are now insanely scrutinized, even though there's
no particular need to do it. And now he's saying,
Oh yeah, there was fraud again, that it was fraud
just as fraudulent again. And it is unbelievable
that people continue to fall for this. But sadly,
this is now standard operating procedure. We we
didn't know back in 2020 whether it was rigged,
it was stolen, would become a broader calling
card or a more frequent refrain for Republicans.
But it is very clear that that is now the case. If
they lose, it was rigged. The world is laughing
and that's where we are at this point in time.